lundi plusieurs influenceurs français
ont révélé avoir reçu une proposition de
partenariat pas comme les autres
objectif faire là contre promotion du
vaccin pfizer contre de l'argent comme
ils l'ont prouvé avec des captures
d'écran laid youtuber ont reçu un mail
d'un certain anton qui travaillerait
pour l' agence files
ce dernier semble décrire sa démarche
comme une campagne informationnel sur la
copie 19 et particulièrement sur les
effets secondaires des vaccins fire et
astrazeneca files précise que dans leur
vidéo les influenceurs ne devront pas
utiliser le mot publicité ou sponsorisés
mais devront présenter les informations
communiquées comme les leurs à ce jour
le profil de cette agence de
communication restent mystérieux son
adresse basé à londres est fictive
son site internet est en partie hébergés
en russie ce même pays où sont basés
quelques-uns de ses employés alors dr
gfk merci d'être là à jérémy alors
comment ça s'est passé a été un temps
approché
comment t'as fait ça j'ai reçu un mail
sur ma boite mail va sur bouyges
compromis et du coup j'étais très
surpris parce que en dehors de tik tok
j'ai pas forcément des chiffres très
très développé et après l'émission tu
vas tout
et du coup il le mail de scrupuleusement
qu'il fallait parler très mal du vaccin
priseur biotech croyable comme par
exemple dire qu'ils avaient en termes de
chiffre trois fois plus de morts
pour les personnes qui prennent le
vaccin weiser biotech par rapport à
astrazeneca
il fallait également parlé des effets
indésirables
et puis plein d'autres choses et donc
partenariat rémunéré demande aucun
crédit
rien du tout ça reste incognito ça c'est
ce qui m'a vraiment surpris j'ai compris
que c'était déjà quelque chose d'illégal
et puis voilà alors on a on a d'autres
voilà qui ont été contactés sagnol a dit
oh que j'adore vous le savez il dit ce
matin j'ai reçu une demande de
partenariat qui m'a grave choqué je suis
obligé de vous en faire par ménage ans
m'a contacté pour partager en échange de
rémunérations des articles qui
décrédibilise le vaccin de pfizer et de
parler de son taux de mortalité en gros
ces gens je sais pas qui est derrière
pai des influenceurs artistes pour faire
de la propagande et de la désinformation
donc si vous voyez des influenceurs
artistes partager ce genre de contenu
sachez qu'il est possible qu'il soit
payé pour dire de la merde on fait
attention et prenez du recul sur ce que
vous lisez sur les réseaux voilà les
eaux grasses et c'est étrange j'ai reçu
une proposition de
partenariat qui consiste à déglinguer le
vaccin kaiser en vidéo budget colossal
client qui veut rester incognito il faut
cacher la sponso voilà si vous voyez des
vidéos là dessus vous saurez que c'est
une opé du coup c'est incroyable voilà
c'est donc si on n'a rien volé njawe où
on leur aurait proposé près de 2000
euros pour chaque story qui
décrédibiliserait le vaccin kraiser et
qu'est ce que vous dites mais je leur
dis d'abord bravo d'avoir dénoncé parce
que s'il n'avait pas dénoncé et si
l'appât du gain a été le plus fort on en
aurait rien su
après visiblement ça vient de la russie
exact c'est une tentative de
déstabilisation c'est d'intelligence et
une origine c'est donc une nourrit une
agence qui s'appelle phase
oui une société où contours troupe qui
pourrait avoir des liens avec la russie
avant la coupe devant qui disent on
assure sa à prendre au conditionnel que
étant donné que le vaccin russe validé
par l'union pas validé par ici notamment
en france et en europe non par et voilà
que ce serait eux qui se met derrière
pour essayer justement de décrédibiliser
les autres actions visiblement parce que
la maison-mère de cette société
d'influencé basé en russie c'est un
oligarque russe qui a été identifiée qui
gérait tout ça ce serait de la
déstabilisation et il faut savoir que si
la vous avez dénoncé
en ce moment il ya une guerre terrible
pour les vaccins les labos une guerre
géostratégique et c'est sûr et c'est sûr
que d'autres n'ont pas eu votre courage
n'ont pas dénoncé et que ça passe c'est
ça qui joue en ce moment
oui nous sommes influencés et là on le
découvre c'est absolument hallucinant
cette histoire on dirait de l'espionnage
moderne à nous est révélée d'un co
incroyable olivero a dit que c'était une
opération minable oui c'est fou parce
qu'on ne sait plus qui croire
oui on se dit c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui ce qui se joue ici au voc
moi cette affaire me dérange un peu
parce que ça nous confirme qu'à
d'énormes enjeux financiers ça ressort
au cours des vaccins badaoui moyens non
non
voyez si vous n'avez sans elle vous aime
beaucoup géré à huy la pluie mouille
c'est une maison donc ça rapporte de
l'argent
ça veut dire quoi ça ben ça envoie le
signal que tout le contraire mais
signale tous les coups sont permis dans
cette industrie est à mon avis les gens
qui sont prêts à payer 2000 euros pour
des story pour dénigrer kaiser ce ne
sont pas des anti vaccins ce sont des
concurrents de pfizer sur ces voix là et
moi ça ne me rassure pas cette histoire
va je trouve que ça envoie le signal que
tous les coups sont permis dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais moi je
vais vous dire quand on va voir des mecs
qui ont fait fortune et qui sont venus
me multimédia d'une pandémie mondiale
bah moi ça me fait chi with all et moi
ce n'est pas ça passe pas donc oui c'est
quand vous vous acceptez toujours dit
vous êtes les béni-oui-oui ducobu encore
ça c'est ce qui rythme qu'on apprend là
c'est terrible c'est à dire que la santé
qui est primordial pour nous pour nos
enfants devient un enjeu financier
mondial et c'est vrai qu'il ya des gens
qui gagnent défendable sur le donne est
changée
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire en plein
jour on joue avec la swija aujourd'hui
il ya des guerres à la nettoie les labos
pharmaceutiques gagnent de l'argent et
valérie ont été tués les vaccins a
révélé on s'entraide gratuit les
batteries j'ai dit contre la wii vous
mais non je dis est ce que vous
découvrez nos veines de l'amant mais sur
des vaccins sont des médicaments wings
qu'on découvre là existe depuis que les
abords il est listé gagne de la baie en
profiter
les beli ex coûter moins bien il ya des
ces normes complot on le voit on voit là
j'irai me hayat docteur guerre qu'est ce
que vous vous rendez compte
c'est incroyable ça franchement et oui
jean aujourd'hui vous voulez comment
voulez croire les gens découvrent en
ayant les chimios et peio non mais on
découvre là gérard malgré chine
découvrez les coulisses de la
communication médiatique là on voit qui
est ça qui sort peut-être qu'il ya plein
de choses qui sont censées commencer
qu'astrazeneca parme s'est fait défoncer
dans les médias entrée ya plein de
polémiques sont sorties au trot
d'astrazeneca
quels sont les coulisses de sa pourquoi
on dit qu aucun problème avec pfizer et
ccd question qu'on peut se poser quand
on voit que dès que ça c'est hallucinant
de voir ça a bien sûr est il des gens
pour mentir parodien on a l'impression
qu'il ya des choses qui se passaient une
guerre derrière nos donne et que les
grecs disent nouveau et que les médias
sont manipulés on les sait depuis le
début toutes des filles annie business
avec les reins
mais le truc du poids de la home on en a
la preuve et on ouvre les yeux vraiment
les gens qui en doutaient encore voit à
quel point ça peut craindre et à quel
point peut pas avoir confiance non mais
je vais vous dire le problème qui est
moi je le vois tous les téléspectateurs
le disent sur les réseaux sociaux
ça c'est très grave a bien sûr on en
décompte ce qui veut dire en fait que
l'imec qui ne pense qu'à une chose la
retirer et mon domicile
et ben voilà des comptines est revu les
gamins dans le tiers-monde parce qu'ils
ne nous ont pas bouffer qui sont pas
soignés ce à quoi ils pensent à
l'intérieur soit pas tombé de l'arbre
l'année passée les compagnies confiance
à ces gens là je la refais pas de quoi
voulez qu'on fasse confiance et l'emploi
se fait l'avocat du diable vient de le
voir en vrai
on sera elle pourquoi israël et les
premiers serviront c'est parce qu'ils
ont payé 2,5 c mais je suis d'accord
avec gratuit devrait y avoir un accident
mais maintenant c'est un bien près après
bisoli temps ici pour moi j'étais pas là
j'étais devant ma télé vous parlait tout
le temps d'israël juste pour rappeler
aux gens en israël ces neuf millions
céline devenu ans israël à arrêter tout
le temps de dire qu'ils ont pu tuer des
clochards parce qu'ils sont déjà 9
millions il se nommait sur un ordi je
vais vous dire quelque chose
raymond lafrance il aurait vu ce qu'on a
en tête je vous dirais c'est bien il
sort et je vous dirai je l'entends un
trou comme ça que je sais qu'ils ont
malgré silicone et comme je vous l ai
dit tout à l'heure la france va être
président de l'union européenne à partir
de janvier
je peux vous dire qu'ils peuvent y aller
le ronde ils peuvent y vont ils vont ils
vont sortir la salariée alors donc ils
peuvent faire arrêter non plus nous
prendre pour des cons
jérémy pau direct tu t'es dit je vais il
fait pas d'y aller ou bien un moment
totalement totalement ça va à l'encontre
déjà de mes principes de mes valeurs et
même par rapport à la demande de
partenariat commencé à annoncer c'est
totalement aussi à l'encontre des règles
d'un partenariat tueur
on cherche à décrédibiliser un produit
alors que pour moi un partenariat
sincère à mettre en avant un produit est
évidemment pas donné de fausses
informations
bien sûr alors oui guillaume il ya deux
choses il ya l'intérêt économique c'est
normal peut-être que les laboratoires
gagnent de l'argent très bien et il ya
la manipulation à dire que gagner
l'argent ok mais manipuler les gens leur
faire dire n'importe quoi pour gagner de
l'argent ça c'est extrêmement c'est pour
ça qu'il soit là je vous dis un problème
politique générale on a vu tout à
l'heure et un instant les réactions de
deux amis et de deux médecins je vous
dis aujourd'hui ça devient compliqué ne
sait plus qui croire et c'est le
problème elle passe les deux oui alors
alors justement un laboratoire
maintenant qu'ils sont bien enrichie on
peut le comprendre parce que la
recherche ça coûte très cher elle a été
rapide et donc il a fallu beaucoup
d'argent maintenant j'espère qu'ils vont
rendre les brevets publiés si c'est un
beau mais ça il sert négociation s'est
pas encore fait
là ça prouverait une forme de générosité
notamment pour l'afrique qui n'auraient
pas à payer tu as aimé
il faut le faire